se faire un resto en famille ou entre
copains c'est bien mais attention à
réserver et surtout annuler si vous
changez d'avis au dernier moment
plusieurs restaurateurs d'Indre-et-Loire
constate un manque à gagner important en
cas de non présentation il faut
désormais payer leurs clients pour des
réservations non honoré pardon exemple
dans cet établissement d'Amboise Hélène
chapelet
pour samedi soir je suis déjà complet
complet sur le papier seulement parce
qu'en réalité je ne sais pas du tout
combien de convives honorant leur
réservation je peux avoir une table ou
deux ou trois ou quatre qui ne viennent
pas ou alors que non seulement
partiellement leur réservation dans la
profession on appelle ça le no show
c'est à dire une réservation non honorée
le phénomène se serait amplifié depuis
la sortie du confinement dans ce
restaurant amboisien cet été sur 50
réservations enregistrées à midi 18
personnes ne se sont jamais présentés un
manque à gagner évident quand le service
est déjà bien avancé et qu'il n'y a plus
de clients de passage pour occuper les
tables réservées mais finalement vides
on a mis en place il y a deux ans la
chaise vide elle a un prix on a estimé
son coup à 15 euros le midi et 25 euros
le soir et c'est le prix qu'on va
facturer ou qu'on se réserve le droit de
facturer en tout cas
aux tables qui arrivent incomplètes dans
notre établissement
autrement dit si vous réservez pour 6
mais que vous ne venez finalement qu'à 4
sans prévenir et que leur restaurateur
ne peut pas proposer les deux places à
d'autres clients il se réserve le droit
de vous les facturer une mesure
clairement affichée sur le site internet
du restaurant et que les clients du jour
comprennent parfaitement
moi je trouve que c'est normal parce que
les gens sont respectueuses quand ils
commandent quand ils réserves une des
places je veux dire c'est s'ils peuvent
pas faut téléphoner ce serait même
d'avis que les restaurateurs prennent un
acompte sur une carte bleue et ne le
redonne pas si les gens ne viennent pas
la mesure qui se veut avant tout
dissuasive reste parfois en travers de
la gorge de ceux qui ont du payer pour
les absents pourtant selon le cogérant
il ne l'aurait appliqué qu'une dizaine
de fois et vous serez un deux mois très
bien bah écoutez merci beaucoup merci de
nous avoir prévenu au revoir